on the indonesian island of sulawesi
these villagers are trying to shelter
under simple tar pollens after their
homes were destroyed by the 6.2
magnitude earthquake
andy sri is worried they're running out
of essentials to survive
we need milk and baby food you see the
conditions
the poor children these are not
conditions for children
makeshift camps like this one have
sprung up around west sulawesi
and authorities are struggling to get
aid to all of them
closer to the city centre evacuation
centers are better resourced
president joko widodo visited one this
week and pledged support for the
affected areas
as for the collapsed houses the
government will provide help for those
that were heavily damaged
but some were not reassured by the
president's words rebuilding the city is
not the priority for many
as they scramble for food and clean
water
we are lacking clean water diapers milk
and blankets
it is so cold here during the night
local ngos and workers from government
agencies say the heavy rain
and challenging geography of the area
makes it difficult to access some
communities
far from the city center
first we need more tents for them the
weather is so unpredictable sometimes it
rains sometimes it's really hot and at
night the wind is so strong and cold
indonesia's disaster management agency
is working with hundreds of military
personnel
and volunteers to reach these makeshift
shelters
in remote areas
together with the police and military we
are delivering aid to those isolated
places with helicopters
to the places we haven't reached yet we
are using heavy machinery to open access
to deliver the aid
it takes time but we are trying our best
and covert 19 travel restrictions have
only added to complications on the
ground
with fewer volunteers available to help
out
just weeks into 2021 indonesia is
battling multiple natural disasters
across the country meteorologists warn
the extreme weather could last
until the end of february and has the
potential to wreak even more havoc
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta